béchir on va les voir encore ce qui se
passe en terrasse parce que j'adore et
hier hier on a offert des voiles à
l'elysée les boissons des trucs là
aujourd'hui on va aller plus loin
regardez ce que j'avais quoi mais ta ta
ta ta ta ta date un cadeau grâce à dell
s'est pas pu y aller elle a des télés on
allait on veut mettre du baume au coeur
dans la vie d'un genre dès les séries
the way les gens sont ressortis oui
merci les chéris il ya de tout pour les
enfants pour les parents rire de tout
c'est grâce à notre partenaire parce que
c'est pas nous qui avons acheté ça moi
je on a réussi à avoir un partenaire un
partenaire b ut attendent le foot il
aime le foot et quand on marque on dit
qu'il ya aussi la belle ayem qui a dû
corner a quand même encore quand même à
la pointe du football à l'ailé chéri on
y va on peint on verra ce qu'on va jouer
à question question pour un glaçon
question pour un garçon s'est passé
alors c'est quoi voilà 7 c'est génial
oui c'est génial
oui c'est génial oui montiel oui vous
n'avez toile et cherré volley ball est
dans la rue
voilà on va aller voir ce qui s'est
passé hier
on va les voir aussi la recette qu'il a
fait notre beau tir parce que hier on a
en booster tout ça donc voilà rien
monsieur bonjour monsieur toi ça va vous
voilà un cadeau cadeaux j'ai plein de
tout cas j'ai plein de trucs là tu
passes à la 5 à ce qu'a dit
vallabrègues la monarchie à trois jours
trois journées jeunes en stage en or
viala là je te pose une question voilà
donné ça lui la tablette la tablette
allez on y va
même si deux tablettes merci beaucoup et
à monsieur karibe la mêlée ce lundi qui
s'est tout lâché lâché le bâlois
voilà est alors vous connaissez question
pour mac ont fait par mon ami noam qui
nous rejoindra l'année prochaine donc
voilà on va à la rencontre des gens
commencent à la commune sa belle famille
amina j'adore amin amin le paa mine de
sel merci amine tu vas jouer john cette
tablette oui tu aimerais la gagner oui
je te pose une question
attention question histoire tu as 30
secondes vont me répondre ces questions
pour un garçon tu vas mettre des glaçons
dans ta bouche c'est parti on y va allez
c'est parti
attention pour cette tablette combien de
temps a duré la guerre de cent ans
[Musique]
j'entends son bus
bien vu si c'est pas ça si c'est beau
c'est pour toi been a bein ouai c'est
gagner voilà tu paraît que ça je
t'embrasse mon chéri salut du meuble
merci des séries merci au revoir ça
c'était ça lui fera salue les frères au
salut merci attention merde comment ça
va ma chérie comment ça va bonjour voila
mais ce que je peux vous offrir un
cadeau alors allons-y caisse kaunas
loupé gens qui adorent pour malades en
moins fréquents comment vous appelez il
vivait pour yvette alors on a quoi c'est
quoi ça c'est quoi les professionnels
regardent ce type mais non france à
rodez grâce à regarder à deux fois car
vapeur pour les professionnels quoi je
vous le donne direct joulin direct vous
me donnez bien sûr merci vous fait des
gros bisous en voir un psy ribbon
journée salut maturi assez bien cimr
estime one c'est génial ça d'effroi
soeur vapeur c'est le numéro un temps ça
a pas de l' air et on va jouer on va
jouer j'ai su ce week-end
[Musique]
salut cycliste jalabert jalabert
jalabert salue quand ça va mon chéri ça
va ça va bien vrai sirh f secure à
l'antenne à l'outil croyais que ces
couches sa mère je peux faire une photo
à
non mais est ce que voulait un petit
cadeau la donne un petit cadeau à mon
avis la donne un petit cadeau mon ami
dans que tu veux là y'a pas un petit
lapin n'a pas duré pour le petit noyau
de la suite à notre ces cadeaux c'est
qu'elle ne veut pas à ses cadres où il
veut pas c'est bon ça va
attention
bon allez on va en terrasse pour hanter
rationnés on va aller voir un peu ce qui
se passe à la terrasse ali chérie c'est
parti rien on va on va faire des cadeaux
on va faire des cadeaux il ya des
cadeaux rial et caddoc terrible un
bonjour quand ça va quand ça va vous
gérez olala c'est énorme
est ce que je peux te plaît à un cadeau
regardez comme il est beau gosse
suscitons tu t'appelles plus pratique tu
vas jouer tout un cadeau au pâtis
baptiste je vais castillo dis moi tu
veux ça tue à hanover bord du passeur
j'ai un ordinateur on en a marre du
devoir donner ce que tu veux attention
on joue pour questionner mondiale sous
les questions attention question on joue
donc avec cette question quelle est la
couleur de la boîte noire d'un avion de
la crise non blanches non
rouge n'ont pas loin or aux plumes à
rabat on allait perdre cette partie là
mon chéri c'est pour toi c'est cadeau ça
thalys et alleo terrassa et ses
partisans à aurillac au 9 mai mais c'est
y règne mais toi tu étais là c'est non
elle était là hier c'est pour moi c'est
cadeau je veux que pensent tous les
jours à l'heure mais celui ci c'est pour
moi toi tu sais que tu viens tu es
tranquille tu es tranquille vaty bon bah
c'est bon c'est bon vent parce que tu
veux voilà tu aurais champagne c'est
cadeau c'est sans panne
il le mérite allez c'est parti on y va
avec madame est ce que voulait jouer
avec moi pour s'allumer nina salut
médina et l'isle adam t-rex à du match
j'avais su avec ta maman pas super voilà
on va essayer de faire là qu'elle a
gagné un beau cadeau à temps avant qu
est ce que tu aimerais qu elle gagne
qu'est-ce que tu es wasquehal y aller on
a plus de 10 est ce que tu veux qu'est
ce que tu as les allées ouais on élu
télé et on a et on a ça et sa grâce au
mag
grâce au magasin b ut grâce au magasin
but et c'est surtout pour ça c'est pour
la télé au jeu pour la télé question
pour un glaçon de vous louer vous rendre
à gaza mais répondent avec le glaçon
attention on joue là pour une télé
une année aidez moi c'est pas ma fille
attention question dans une course
cycliste
si je double le deuxième en quelle
position je suis deuxième
deuxième nature comme eva premier à
l'ailé c'est bon on s'en fout du glas
sur le terrain pendant les règles
le djia sont l'occasion sega des
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
passants occupez vous restez la malaisie
on va vous mettre la [ __ ]
allez c'est parti là tu veux gagner des
cadeaux londubat balades à poney et la
terrasse et pour moi c'est pour moi ici
c'est pour moi vraiment mais c'est pour
moi le jeu là le relais c'est pour moi
ici c'est pour moi et ceux qui veulent
prendre un verre c'est maintenant c'est
pour moi ça français blanc prend le
petit mère adoptive et enfin ouvrir
alors venez comment ça va les chéris
c'est bien on va vous appeler iman n'est
pas tenu à doha lors adam n'a pas cadeau
pour un dans un canal alors là mais à
quoi qu'on fasse de consoles de jeux
consoles de salon
bonsoir deux autres consoles de jeux
allez on va jouer donc pour une console
en mai laisse tomber le garçon t'emmerde
pas aller au fond jouko
fond de jeu attention question quel mot
est considéré comme étant le plus long
de la langue française sillonné le monde
entier kwakwa anticonstitutionnellement
ah ah
alors il y avait le nôtre notre sniper
qui isole et là dessus parce qu'ils sont
merci merci guen sont couverts c'est
vrai ils sont très très bon styliste son
traitement
merci d'avoir été là c'est un gros
baiser c'est bon c'est pour nous cette
intention et rap us merci à les cherry
qui veut voir avec lui c'est pour toi tu
vois un cadre en plus alors alors lui
donc ouais non satisfaits d'avoir déjà
un truc avoir paddle après je m'occupe
de toi comment ça va très bien très bien
tu vois pas de leurs sept français louis
amancic hall tu veux qu'on joue cette
chaîne a volontiers en fait rigoler tout
en jouant dimanche dimanche qu'elle est
à dimanche et deux jacks novak et femme
du ve samedi je peu après au match de
tennis à 15h 17h il cette heure c'est
faisable il rigole pas super super
survient trois gorges a mais la gamme
plus non non comme que jamais la garde
c'est fait bon déjà pas d'aller déjà 110
ans qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et lussan
sportifs ont regardé ébahis isabelle il
est beau c'est sûr qu'ils jouent mais
l'inspiration le csa doit tout de suite
adoré board ça va ça va très bien
hannover bratton joue pour un over bleu
alors là on va jouer une question tennis
que j'ai dans la tête ce poulain
question tennis attention vous avez
commandé 20 antoine antoine antoine vous
avant votre âge où on a annoncé 48 48
this on dit 48 des musiques quoi ça
continue à regarder moscou 3-0
magnifique j'en rigole effet monsieur
cordoue j'avais une belle vache c'est
fou fou alors attention aux dons joue au
tennis ou wii qui te soit 15,5 l'a5
sportback sa commentaires à 15 heures
hier à castres cette année l'année
blanche denis blanc 58 ans c'est
beaucoup c'est bon alors très simple qui
a gagné
roland garros attention qui a gagné
roland garros en 84 81
[Musique]
84 83 c'est notre ville en deux wilander
près bonne réponse c'est magique
[Applaudissements]
attendez on m'appelle je rajoute au yen
à 87 85 5 85 85 85 6085 rajoute un
cadeau sinon je retire suis allé 85 ou
non la d86 tiens je crois non c'est ça
non quoique tu chantes sur ses 89 89
mais 85 c lin d'oeil c'est sûr merci un
nom des auteurs ouais c'est là qu'est
parti ce que je suis mais déjà il a les
il ya des masses pour tout le monde ça
va merci là alors je me suis vengé merci
et bravo jouer ça va tu as lu ben
jean-jacques jean-jacques comment
georges a eu jean jacques
[Rires]
attention attention 20 voile et obtient
un petit truc les trois pages m'occupe
de temps alors comment ça va quand vous
appelez bape et christine salut
christine mariatte à côté elle va tarder
à mon mari s'il me christine est ce que
tu veux gagner un cadeau
oui bien sûr tu m'as barbecue à
barbechat barbecue la grâce et la caf il
pas mal non alors pour le barbecue c'est
parti le barbecue contre les squats
question
mccaw bonne question elle va cadeau aux
yeux bandés sur les îles se pose une
question facile et vous allez voir vous
allez voir je cite je pose une question
facile
comment je m'appelle
[Applaudissements]
merci ma chérie eh ben c'est à marie
alors alors attention à distance de
sécurité on a encore rehaussé quoi sa
tension
bah oui attention aux masses comme sa
voix la tendance quand vous appelez vous
prenez un beau gosse rooney et oui très
bien très bel organe non en tout cas
[Musique]
rené l on n'a qu'à l'aube où rené de
choplin tour de son ans que je sois pas
là dessus
mach est une machine à café on est à 80
en questions de café à mes questions
deutsch a fait sortir sans merci
alors question qu'a fait attention
question café voici la question quel
était le prénom de gringos 'qe-2' vabres
s'était gaussé gagner quand même merci
de cette fête c'est bon on les bat
pauline c'est parti allait atteindre les
canots un bon pote
alors regardez regardez ce podcast
regarder ce beau gosse ça va mon chéri
ferai demain ça va être beau tu
t'appelles enfin il est beau gosse quand
un bon toi papa côtes à côtes d'armor
quant à que je suis très plaisir
entretien des comptines était alors
attention mon chéri ça va mon chéri tu
avec quentin et les bons les magnifiques
c'est ton fils wade est magnifique
t'inquiète je t'offre un cadeau inquiète
pas megan trottinette électrique alors
attention je vais donc te poser une
question sur les transports comment
s'appelle le ministre des transports
alors jean baptiste jean baptiste
baptisait marie jo bâton le pack halo
pour le petit adro vrais emplois dont tu
voudras pas les voilà les chinois ont
fait un dernier tour de piste qui veut
jouer bien ma chérie aller là comment tu
t'appelles comptant 1
anna salua nashiri salut regardez moi ce
brunch va dépit anna qu'est ce que tu
veux comme cadeau à rebours pâtissier
qu'est ce que beaucoup attention à leur
casque à vous tous de questions que jcs
question musique émotions question
musique quel titre qui a repris le titre
nuit de folie quel rapport a repris le
titre nuit de folie dernièrement du
pilat entendu tu leur donnes du oui
joyce et bien je salue les policiers
1 et se produit seul parti merci balle
est venue à hu est lui aussi sa peine
enfin qu'elle doit de attention le
cadeau un cadeau chacun qu'est ce que
vous voulez il ya des craintes beauté
magnifique séjour en europe en adoubant
à ses jours en europe
regardez à s'y joindre attention la
question donc va porter sur l'europe
je vous demande et deux capitales quelle
est la capitale déjà ici il faudra deux
points sur deux qu'elle est la capitale
de la roumanie
[Musique]
alors ok pas de réponse elle aurait à
lui maintenant qu'elle est la capitale
attention de la slovaquie où elle est
venue je sais pas
la capitale de la slovaquie
j'entends là bas je l'entends lama s'est
dit ainsi sa rage
voilà le seuil c'était le projet merci
champagne et si ça sert ici ça marche
quand ça joue ici sa part ces parties
ont débattu droits d'escale allez
maintenant tout à saturne c'est parti à
madame c'est parti au passage qui veut
du match aller face à tottenham mais
sébastien organe que messi tu porteras
temps des médias koala l'europe ont tous
les arts qui veulent voir